hallo mein Name ist Sky du Mont und ich
präsentiere euch den dunklen Januar ein
Tatort Deutschland Spezial jeden Tag ein
neuer Kriminalfall
und mein Name ist Natalie Strauß moin
wir graben für euch Fälle aus die
Jahrhunderte zurückliegen oder gerade
erst geschehen sind Fälle aus weiter
Ferne oder auch wie heute Fälle aus der
unmittelbaren Nachbarschaft
ich bin Radiomoderatorin in Hamburg und
das Verbrechen und das ist heute geht
hat sich im Juni letzten Jahres eine
Autostunde südlich von meiner
Heimatstadt abgespielt bevor wir
loslegen will ich darauf hinweisen dass
es in diesem Fall keine veröffentlichten
Namen gibt diese sind in unserer
Erzählung frei erfunden
bei dieser Geschichte kann ich nur den
Kopf schütteln und das tue ich nicht
allein auch heute an meiner Seite
Sprecher und Moderator Mirko Kasimir
hello hallo Nathalie schön dich zu sehen
es ist Freitag der 10 Juni 2022
während im Osten und Südwesten
Deutschlands die 30 Gradmarke geknackt
wird sind es im nördlichen Bergdorf bei
Bienenbüttel angenehme 23 Grad und
Sonnenschein
der letzte Regen liegt knapp eine Woche
zurück und die Bewohner einer kleinen
ehemaligen Ferienhaussiedlung genießen
den Start in ein frühsommerliches
Wochenende man kennt sich während dem
Hauptort rund 300 Einwohner leben sind
es in dieser von Wald und Feldern
umgebenden idyllischen Siedlung nur eine
Handvoll Menschen die Grundstücke des
Ehepaars Schmidt und von Herrn Müller
liegen unmittelbar nebeneinander
mit je 1500 Quadratmetern nicht zu klein
und nicht zu groß einander nah und doch
rückt man sich nicht auf die Pelle
vielleicht haben beide Parteien sogar
vor ein paar Jahren mal auf gute
Nachbarschaft angestoßen
das wäre auf jeden Fall verdammt lang
her seit die Frau des 85-jährigen
Rentners Müller im Altersheim ist will
auch er weg aus der Gegend ihn hält
nichts mehr dort nichts mehr im Haus und
vor allem nichts mehr in der Nähe seiner
Nachbarn das anfangs vielleicht mit
kleineren Streitigkeiten begonnen hat
soll in einer riesigen Tragödie Enden
Mirko weiter am Text was für ein Problem
hatten der Männer mit den Schmitz
naja während es die Anfang 60-Jährigen
auch mal feuchtfröhlich mögen Wilhelm
Müller einfach nur seine Ruhe haben er
ist kein Mann für große Partys er liebt
die Abgeschiedenheit und ist Garn in der
Natur
gerade erst im April ist sein Jagdschein
erneuert worden der Herr Müller über 80
Jahre alt ist muss er eine jährliche
Zuverlässigkeitsprüfung ablegen das wird
noch wichtig für diese Geschichte denn
der Rentner hat ganz legal mehrere
Waffen bei sich zu Hause
ein anderer Anwohner der Siedlung
beschreibt ihn im Nachhinein als ruhig
und friedlich Herr Müller war ein
anständiger Mann
er habe unter dem Ehepaar Schmidt
gelitten und sich von ihnen provoziert
gefühlt sie seien unter anderem nackt
durch ihren Garten gelaufen für den Jahr
so anständigen Herrn Müller absolut
daneben immer wieder kommt es zum Streit
wie häufig es über die Jahre zu
Auseinandersetzungen kam und wie
intensiv diese waren können wir nur
mutmaßen aber es scheint sich eine Menge
Wut angesteuert zu haben
womöglich haben sich die 61-Jährige und
ihr 62 Jahre alte Ehemann über den
Rentner lustig gemacht
ernst genommen haben sie seine Wut
jedenfalls nicht
und so ruhig und so friedlich wer von
anderen beschrieben wird ist Herr Müller
definitiv nicht die Nachbarschaft
Streitigkeiten sind schon längst Polizei
bekannt ich war Mirko es ist richtig
denn schon vor dem finalen Streit im
Juni 2022 ist die Polizei mehrfach so
weitsiedlung ausgerückt
Wortgefechte Beleidigungen bei den alten
Herrschaften ist es wenig friedlich
zugegangen die Schmitz haben gern
gefeiert Herr Müller gern geschehen hat
eine explosive Mischung
absurde Streitigkeiten zwischen Nachbarn
sind ja erstmal nicht zu ungewöhnliches
ich erinnere mich daran einen gewissen
Maschendrahtzaun
1999 hat eine Frau ihren Nachbarn
angezeigt weil dessen Knallerbsenstrauch
ihren Maschendrahtzaun beschädigte das
ganze war so abgedreht und skurril das
Stefan Raab doch damals gemeinsam mit
der Country Band Truck Stop mit draus
gemacht
aber trotzdem abgewiesen worden der
Strauch durfte stehen bleiben in unserem
Fall heute sorgt kein Strauch sondern
zwei Bäume dafür dass alles vollkommen
eskaliert
ja und Auslöser allen Unheils ist ein
Sturm wie wir schon beschrieben haben
stehen auf den Grundstücken der Siedlung
in bargdorf viele Bäume es ist fast als
würden die Häuser in einem kleinen Wald
stehen
erst vor kurzem ist ein Sturm über die
Gegend gefegt und hat zum Teil größere
Schäden hinterlassen
ein Baum ist auf das Gästehaus der
Schmitz gestürzt und hat es stark
beschädigt
zwei Bäume auf Herrn Müllers Grundstück
die direkt neben dem von Ehepaar Schmidt
stehen scheinen nach dem Sturm Kurzform
Umstürzen oder zumindest abbrechen zu
sein
Frau und Herr Schmidt fordern daher dass
diese Bäume aus Sicherheitsgründen
gefällt werden
klingt für mich jetzt erstmal nach einer
plausiblen und logischem Wetter ich
meine ein Baum hat schon ein Haus von
ihnen demoliert außerdem Sachschaden ist
ja zum Glück nichts weiter geschehen
aber natürlich möchte man jetzt auf
Nummer sicher gehen dass da in naher
Zukunft nicht schlimmeres passiert aber
das sieht Herr Müller überhaupt nicht
ein ja denn so logisch das auch klingen
mag letzten Endes müssen alle
Beteiligten Anwohner dem Fällen der
Bäume zustimmen
die Bäume stehen auf Herrn Müllers
Grundstück und stellen für ihn offenbar
keine Gefahr da die Schmitz können also
nicht einfach rübergehen und loslegen es
ist schließlich nicht ihr Grundstück
die Diskussion zwischen den beiden
Parteien werden immer hitziger Herr
Müller scheint mittlerweile alles als
Angriff zu werden
er fühlt sich definitiv provoziert
logisches Denken und der Wunsch auf ein
friedliches Miteinander sind wohl schon
lange dahin
wir gehen an den Vormittag des 10 Juni
hier könnten mehrere Streitigkeiten
zusammengekommen sein
[Musik]
es ist ein Freitagmittag um die
Essenszeit der Auftakt ins Wochenende
ein großer Streitpunkt zwischen Ehepaar
Schmidt und Müller ist dass die Schmitz
wohl gern schon ab dem Mittag zu feiern
beginnen oder zumindest geht es
fröhlicher und auch mal lauter zu
das passt Herrn Müller so oder so nicht
lasst uns also folgendes spekulieren
Frau und Herr Schmidt setzen sich zum
Mittagessen raus vielleicht wird bei dem
schönen Wetter der Grill angeschmissen
dazu ein kühles Bierchen oder ein
kleines Sektchen geöffnet die beiden
unterhalten sich angeregt lachen laut
ein Huhn in den Ohren von Herrn Müller
schon wieder diese mit tägliche
Ruhestörung die beiden scheinen sich
über ihn lustig zu machen
das Lachen und die Streitigkeiten der
letzten Tage rund um die Bäume auf dem
Gelände bringen das Fass schließlich zum
Überlaufen jetzt reicht es Herr Müller
der beschließt ein für alle mal Schluss
zu machen mit dieser Ignoranz und
Arroganz seiner Nachbarn er geht rüber
und stellt die Schmitz zur Rede schnell
wird es laut
plötzlich ein Schuss
Schreie
dann noch ein Schuss
und Stille
unfassbar ich meine wir reden hier immer
noch über einen Streit um Bäume
das ganze bleibt natürlich nicht
ungehört es ist mitten am Tag ab 12 Uhr
15 Uhr mittags und andere Anwohner hört
das ganze knallen und alarmiert die
Polizei und da der 85-Jährige Müller
eine jagdlizenz besitze man weiß dass er
Waffen bei sich haben könnte rücken die
Beamten mit einem Großaufgebot an
schnell wird aus der idyllischen
Siedlung ein belebter Tatort sowas hat
es hier noch nicht gegeben
vor Ort sind Spezialkräfte aus Hamburg
das mobile Einsatzkommando aus Lüneburg
und das SEK Hannover auch ein
gepanzertes Einsatzfahrzeug rollt
die Beamten betreten das Holzhaus der
Schmitz und können nichts mehr tun
sie finden drei Leichen Frau Schmidt
Herrn Schmidt und Herrn Müller
alle drei erschossen
boah heftig das erscheint zunächst
äußerst rätselhaft der alte hat also die
Nachbarn im Streit offenbar erschossen
aber wer hat ihn getötet wenn er nach
Jahren der Konflikte schießt sich
ausrastet warum sollte er sich dann
selber richten
aber so und nicht anders muss es noch
Einschätzung der Ermittler gewesen sein
der Täter besitzt drei Waffen zwei
Langwaffen und eine Kurzwaffe die
blutart hat er mit der Kurzwaffe
begangen
was immer Herrn Müller so wütend gemacht
hat es endet mit dem Tod von drei
Menschen erst hatte das Ehepaar
erschossen und dann sich selbst
gerichtet
das ist aus so vielen Ebenen einfach nur
absurd die Polizei geht von einer
absoluten Kurzschlussreaktion aus mehr
wird zu dieser Tat nicht gesagt was mich
total beschäftigt ist dass dieser
anscheinend ach so friedliche alte
85-Jährige her zu so einer Tat überhaupt
fähig ist okay er hat Waffen zu Hause
aber wo fängt denn überhaupt diese
Kurzschlussreaktion an ich kann mir
vorstellen dass der sich da drüben in
seinem Haus so reingesteigert hat dass
er sich vielleicht seine Waffe genommen
hat um die Nachbarn zu Rede zu stellen
ich weiß es nicht dann ist das Ganze
eskaliert er hat seine Nachbarn
abgeknallt dann realisiert oh Gott was
mache ich ja eigentlich aus dieser
Nummer komme ich ja auch nicht mehr
wieder raus ja okay dann gehe ich halt
mit also anders kann ich mir das auch
überhaupt gar nicht erklären
aber noch mal warum nimmt man eine Waffe
mit zu seinen Nachbarn zum drohen oder
wie ich meine du musst ja schon in
gewissen Hintergedanken dabei haben aber
die Wahrheit werden wir natürlich nie
erfahren Mirko wie sieht's bei dir aus
naja ist ein Fall der eigentlich in
einem normalen und unspektakulären
Umfeld stattgefunden hat aber leider
sind ja Nachbarschaftsstreitigkeiten
überhaupt keine Seltenheit auch nicht in
Deutschland und in diesem Fall hat sich
durch den Streit über die Zeit glaube
ich immer mehr Druck aufgebaut und der
hat sich dann einfach in diesem
mörderischen Ausbruch waren gebrochen
und die Nachbarn waren nicht gewillt
sich gegenseitig aus dem Weg zu gehen
oder Rücksicht aufeinander zu nehmen und
irgendwann war diese Wut und offenbar
auch der Hass so groß dass Herr Müller
bereit war zu töten
seine Nachbarn und sich selbst die
Umstände unter denen das eskaliert ist
die machen mich nachdenklich das sind
drei Menschen die an sich ein gutes
Leben haben ja verhältnismäßig
wohlhabend mit einem eigenen Grundstück
Häuschen im Grünen ja also eigentlich so
ein bisschen paradiesisch aber es sind
halt leider komplett unterschiedliche
Charaktere die in der Kombination
absolut toxisch wirken ich denke es ist
auf jeden Fall auch in Appell und uns
alle dass wir mehr aufeinander acht
geben müssen und falls wir merken dass
wir in einer Situation geraten die
irgendwie keinen Ausweg bietet dass wir
gewillt sind uns auch Hilfe zu suchen ja
in diesem Fall könnte man einen Mediator
oder einen Streitschlichter zu Rate
ziehen einfach damit man eine weitere
Eskalation verhindern kann
aber so oder so wir danken euch fürs
Zuhören nicht nur bei Groß und Fällen
die die ganze Welt bewegen sondern auch
bei kleinen Tragödien die scheinbar
jeden treffen können wir freuen uns wenn
auch bei der nächsten Folge wieder dabei
seid bei Tatort Deutschland Spezial euer
Mirko und eure Natalie
den Fall des nachbarschaftsmordes in der
Lüneburger Heide haben wir mit
bildartikeln der Bild am Sonntag einem
Beitrag des NDR und der Hannoverschen
Allgemeinen Zeitung nacherzählt
Redaktion Stefan Netzeband und Antonia
Haier Produktion Marvin schwarz